- Il y a un peu plus d'un an
dans cet immeuble à condos de
Griffintown, un copropriétairere
a eu une mauvaise surprise alors
qu'il faisait la vaisselle.
JEAN-SÉBASTIEN CÔTÉ, admin.(,
- Le lavabo a cédé n'a
pas tenu, et tout l'eau qu'il
contenait s'est répandu
par terre. Et ça a causé
un sinistre.
Alors, on a dû faire appel à des
experts en sinistre pour
nettoyer le tout, faire assécher
les parties, enlever les
planchers, refaire les moulures.
- Le dégât d'eau ât d'eau ât d'e
uniquement l'unité en question.
- Ça a pas touché personne
en bas.
- Le syndicat de copropriété
mène ensuite les travaux
de réparation.
Selon la loi, il en
a l'obligation.
- Ça a coûté environ 20 000 $,
faire tout réparer ça.
- Puis, il se tourne vers
ur du copropriétaire
pour qu'il paie la note, mais
suit un refus.
- L'assureur dit qu'il n'est pat
qu'il faut avant tout, nous, le
syndicat de copropriété,
démontrer qu'il y a faute.
Et le démontrer, la force de laa
vaisselle... ça devient un peu
difficile.
- Le syndicat de copropriété ne
peut pas être indemnisé par son
assureur puisque le montant desa
franchise qui est de 50 000 $.
C'est donc le syndicat lui-même,
c'est-à-dire l'ensemble
des copropriétaires qui doivent
éponger la facture.
ication d'un article
du Code civil en 2018 a changé
la façon dont les compagnies
d'assurances indemnisent
leurs clients en copropriété.
Auparavant, les copropriétaires
touchés par un sinistre
était dédommagé presque
automatiquement
par leur assureur.
AUCHESNE,présidente,
Asso. québ.gestionnaires copro.
- Même si le copropriétaire
n'était pas responsable, son
assureur pouvait réparer
chez lui lorsqu'il y avaitdes d.
Donc, ça simplifie à l'époque
la résolution des plus petit
sinistre qui était en deçà de
la franchise du syndicat parce
que chaque copropriétaire allait
faire appel à son propre
assureur.
Me STEFANIA CHIANETTA,avocate,
arbitre en droit de copropriété
- Dorénavant, tu dois prouver
une faute ou une responsabilité
de mon assuré pour que je
te rembourse la franchise
ou le montant des travaux.
Les syndicats sont
engager des experts en sinistre
privé eux-mêmes pour être en
mesure de faire leurs preuves.
Donc, il y a des frais
qui s'accumulent.
- Selon l'avocate,
les compagnies d'assurance
se laissent difficilement
convaincre leur asne
part de responsabilité lorsque
sinistre se déclare dans son
unité.
on s'est rendu compte,
c'est qu'au fur et à mesure,
c'était des refus presque
systématiques des assureurs,
des copropriétaires.
- c'est faut de dire que les
assureurs refusent
systématiquement de payer
l y a des réclamations
pour une franchise dans le cas
d'un sinistre.
- Selon le bureau d'assurance du
Canada, les dossiers litigieux
ne représentent qu'une minorité
des réclt les
assureurs s'acquittent de leurs
responsabilités.
- Un bain qu'on laisse couler et
qui déborde et qui caus
des dommages, bien, c'est assez
responsabilité
à l'occupant des lieux. Et à ce
moment-là, l'assureur payerait,
mais c'est pas toujours évident
de déterminer ça.
Ça, c'est des cas simples, mais
y avoir des cas aussi
qui sont un peu plus compliqués.
- Des cas plus compliqués comme
un lave-vaisselle qui coule.
- On a un copropriétaire qui
achetait un nouveau lave-
vaisselle, le lave-vaisselle
était défectueux, probablementuu
manufacturier, et l'assureur du
copropriétaire, quand le lave-
vaisselle a fait défaut causa un
dégât d'eau, il nous a env
côté du syndicat vers le
manufacturier du lave-vaisselle.
- Je pense que c'est aux
copropriétaires de poursuivr
soit le fabricant ou
l'installateur, et non pas
au syndicat.
- L'association québécoise des
gestionnaires de copropriété
réclame des changements la loi
pour faciliter la démonstration
de la faute de copropriétaire
quand un sinistre provient de
son unit
- On s'assure pour une situation
imprévisible pour avoir une paix
d'esprit, ça
cause beaucoup plus
d'inconvénients aux gens, en
fait, et de stress parce qu'ils
ne savent jamais si leur
assureur va payer ou non.
- Le ministre des finances Eric
Girard q
du dossier ce qui concerne lespe
revoir la loi.
- On a un robinet de salle
de bain laissé ouvert,
une fuite de drain d'air
climatisé...
- Mais entre-temps, les
sinistres s'accumulent
et les factures aussi.
- On finit par éponger les coûts
et les déficits et tout ça,
puis on n'en est rendue à plus
de 100 000 $ de notre côté.
- Avec les nouvelles règles,
plusieurs syndicats de
copropriété en impression de
s'être transformé
d'assurances.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, M